so jetzt schauen wir aber was uns an
diesem Nachmittag erwartet der
zuständige Minister ist jetzt auf der
Regierungsbank also in vielen Kliniken
trifft derzeit ja die Zunahme von
corona-patienten auf einen dramatischen
Personalmangel Gesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach der plant nun Pflegekräfte zu
entlasten die Bundesregierung will
Krankenhäuser verpflichten eine
ausreichende Zahl von Pflegekräften zu
beschäftigen im Mittelpunkt steht ein
neues System zur Personalbemessung das
soll stufenweise eingeführt werden ab
2025 dann verbindlich gelten der
Bundestag berät also heute in erster
Lesung ein Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung zur
pflegepersonalbemessung im
krankenhaushaus sowie zur Anpassung eine
weitere Regelung da geht es auch um
Digitalisierung und
Verwaltungsvereinfachung so können wir
den Minister Karl Lauterbach
frau Präsidentin meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute geht es
um das
pflegeentlastungsgesetz oft ist es ja
bei Gesetzen so dass man nicht weiß was
ich hinter dem Namen des Gesetzes
verbirgt hier könnten die Dinge nicht
einfacher sein es geht um die Entlastung
in der Pflege und weshalb brauchen wir
die Entlastung in der Pflege naja wir
haben die Situation dass in der Pflege
die Situation sich seit Jahren zu
darstellt dass die Pflege belastet ist
und zunehmend belasten ist und das hat
sich durch die Pandemie eher verstärkt
und verschlechtert was geht nicht nur
für die krankenhauspflege sondern auch
für Langzeitpflege wir sind aber heute
insbesondere mit der
krankenhauspflege beschäftigt und hier
haben wir die Belastung wir haben zum
einen sehr viele stationäre Betten im
internationalen Vergleich wir haben sehr
viele Eingriffe die eigentlich auch
ambulant erbracht werden könnten und wir
haben lange liege dauern außerdem ist
die Pflege in Deutschland so
strukturiert dass viele auf waren die
der Pflege eigentlich vorenthalten sein
könnten nicht von der Pflege erbracht
werden dürfen somit ist die Pflege in
vielerlei Hinsicht nicht so genutzt wie
sie genutzt werden könnte zu viele
stationäre Aufenthalte die Pflege wird
nicht voll in diese Bereiche gebracht wo
sie arbeiten wo sie helfen könnte und
dann eine Dauerbelastung was kann dieses
Gesetz also beitragen um der um dieser
Problematik Herr zu werden wir müssen
die Arbeitsbedingungen verbessern und
dazu muss erst einmal
stationsgenau festgehalten werden wie
ist die Belastungssituation und das kann
man in denen eben dokumentiert wird
welche Pflege notwendig wäre und das
vergleicht mit der Pflege die vorhanden
ist daraus kann man die tatsächliche
Belastung dann ableiten und wenn man das
abgeleitet hat dann soll es dabei nicht
bleiben sondern dann folgt dann eine
Entlastung diese Entlastung kann zum
Beispiel darin bestehen dass wir FE Tage
mehr freie Tage also eingeführt werden
dass also Schichten abgebaut werden dass
es zu mehr Urlaub kommt dass es zu
Entlastungen kommt oder auch zu einer
besseren Vergütung und wenn das nicht
anders geht dann können auch bestimmte
Leistungen die nur erbracht werden
können weil die Pflege überlassen ist
sie können da nicht mehr angeboten
werden da muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
dann ist auch die ein oder andere
Operation nicht mehr durchzuführen wenn
eine überflüssige Operation durchgeführt
wird auf Kosten der Pflege aber da auf
Kosten einer dauerhaften Überlastung der
Pflege dann ist das nicht hinzunehmen
somit kann man das Gesetz auch wie folgt
beschreiben wir machen hier
ernst mit einer Entlastung der Pflege
wer dokumentieren die Überlastung wir
führen Sanktionen ein und diese
Sanktionen können dann auch so weit
gehen dass bestimmte Leistungen nicht
mehr erbracht werden können soweit sind
wir hier bereit zu gehen
was dafür genutzte Instrument ppa2.0 ist
das Ergebnis der konzertierten Aktion
wir haben das im Koalitionsvertrag
festgeschrieben dass wir das umsetzen
wollen das machen wir jetzt es wird aber
nicht die einzige Maßnahme sein mit der
wir die Pfleger entlasten werden wir
haben hier zunächst einmal die Situation
dass wir viele Eingriffe machen die in
Deutschland stationär durchgeführt
werden mit einer Übernachtung wo die
Übernachtung medizinisch eigentlich gar
nicht indiziert ist und oft mehr
Probleme bringt als die Probleme löst da
wollen wir mit
Tagespauschalen das auch Tages also das
quasi die also DRG die fahrpauschale
abgerechnet werden kann ohne dass man
übernachtet insbesondere die
Schichtdienste in der Pflege abbauen das
ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt wir haben
dann weniger Schichtdienste in der
Pflege das wäre eine wesentliche
Entlastung zum zweiten wir wollen genau
prüfen welche ein welche also Eingriffe
sind möglicherweise ganz eine stationäre
Versorgung möglich daher denen wir den
Katalog aus von Leistungen die auch
ambulant erbracht werden können die wir
derzeit stationär erbringen um den
stationären Bereich auf das
zurückzudrängen was medizinisch
notwendig ist und zum dritten wir wollen
darüber hinaus die Pflege auch so
gestalten dass Pflegekräfte auch die
Leistungen erbringen können für die sie
ausgebildet worden sind in Deutschland
ist die Ausbildung oft viel besser als
das was in der Pflege dann gelastet
werden kann weil viele Eingriffe viele
Verrichtungen der Pflege nicht erlaubt
sind obwohl sie diese sehr gut machen
können wir wollen daher den Beruf
professionalisieren auch stärker
akademisieren aber auch in der vollen
Blüte zur Tragen kommen lassen so dass
wir mit dieser Entlastung also mehrere
Achsen gleichzeitig verfolgen Entlastung
der Pflege durch die also durch den
Abbau von Schichten in der Nacht dann
eben das
pflegeentlastungsinstrument wo wir die
Überlastung sichtbar machen wo unsere
Sanktionen kommen und bessere Nutzung
der Pflege indem wir die Pflegekräfte
auch an Leistungen heranbringen für die
sie erstklassig ausgebildet sind die sie
bisher nicht machen durften das macht
wird den Beruf attraktiver sein
ich komme zum Schluss also dieses
Gesamtpaket ist aus meiner Sicht aus
einem Guss es ist ein Paket wo wir auch
bereit sind Geld in die Hand zu nehmen
denn bessere Pflege ist teurer das muss
ja auch gesagt werden das ist teurer
aber es wird insbesondere eine bessere
Versorgung sein wir haben dann also
lange arbeiten wir mehrere Sätze
hintereinander bringen aber dieses
kurzfristige pflegeentlastungsgesetz das
ist wirklich etwas worauf die Pflege
sehr lange schon wartet was wir schnell
einführen werden womit wir die
Transparenz bekommen die wir benötigen
und um die Pflege zu entlasten und auch
jetzt ist nicht alles schlecht weil wir
diese Schritte gehen weil jeder war es
dass wir da ernst machen ist die Zahl
der Auszubildenden in der Pflege wieder
gestiegen auch die Zahl der
Vollzeitkräfte in der Pflege ist wieder
gestiegen und auch die Bezahlung steigt
somit ist es nicht alles schlecht wir
gehen nach vorne etwas langsamer als es
sein müsste aber man darf die Pflege
nicht kleiner reden als sie ist ohne die
Pflege werden wir anlassung durch die
wir konnten durch die Pandemie gekommen
die deutsche Pflege steht stark und wir
werden Sie weiter starten vielen Dank
so und das der Gesetzentwurf von Karl
Lauterbach wird hier heute vorgelegt
also ein neues System zur
Personalbemessung stufenweise soll es
eingeführt werden letztendlich um
Pflegekräfte zu entlassen und natürlich
auch eine bessere Versorgung der Kranken
zu erreichen
Heinrich Dietrich monstadt jetzt für die
Union
stellen sich folgendes vor ihr Kind
braucht dringend medizinische Hilfe doch
der Krankenwagen fährt von einem
Krankenhaus zum nächsten weil die
Krankenhäuser keine Patienten mehr
aufnehmen und Ihr Kind deshalb nicht
schnell und angemessen behandelt werden
kann das ist keine Fiktion meine Damen
und Herren sondern eine Realität hier
bei uns hier in der Hauptstadt unser
Krankenhäuser sind so überfordert dass
sie kaum Patienten aufnehmen können
wachsende Defizite der Wegfall von
corona-ausgleichszahlungen statt
nierende stationäre Fallzahlen und Erlös
Ausfälle durch Personalmangel Inflation
steigende energiekostenvor
auf erwartbare Blackouts Spitzen die
Lage dramatisch zu Herr Minister ernst
ist hier dringend geboten die Maßnahmen
dieser Regierung dieser Koalition kommen
zu spät es kommt schlichtweg zu wenig
umgeben entgegenzutreten beziehungsweise
um unsere Einrichtungen zu entlasten
brauchen diese Häuser einen
rückwirkenden Inflationsausgleich meine
Damen und Herren von der Koalition wo
bleibt hier der doppelwumms unser
krankenhäuser müssen seit Jahren mit
immer größeren Problemen kämpfen
bestehende Investitionsstaus eine
Pandemie die das gesamte medizinische
Personal an die Grenzen gebracht hat und
ein Krieg im Herzen Europas der
steigende Energiekosten und Inflation
verursacht viele dieser Krankenhäuser
sind in schweren wirtschaftlichen
Schieflagen
Herr Bundesminister sie müssen dringend
handeln und nach meiner Wahrnehmung
sollte die Regierung sich weniger mit
dem legalisieren von kiffen beschäftigen
sie sollen endlich die wirklichen
Probleme angehen
dass ihr kommt alles noch Salz das hier
vorliegende Gesetz mit zum Beispiel der
Regelung zu PPR 2.0 ist nicht nur
handwerklich mangelhaft sondern vor
allem inhaltlich es bietet faktisch
keine Entlastung für unsere
Krankenhäuser meine Kollegin Frau
Borchert wird hier zu näheres ausführen
im Gegenteil im Gesetz vorgesehene
Regelungen zu dokumentations- und
nachweisverpflichtungen für unseren
Bürokratieaufwand Krankenhäuser ihre
bereits begrenzen Personalkapazitäten im
Bereich der präsentenversorgung dringend
brauchen müssen Pflegepersonal nun für
diesen erhöhten Bürokratieaufwand
einsetzen bei nichtbevölkerung drohen
sogar Sanktionen die die wirtschaftliche
Situation weiter verschärfen
unsere Krankenhäuser meine Damen und
Herren brauchen mehr Flexibilität
richtig wäre ein dynamisches System
welches eigenverantwortlich vor Ort
Entscheidungen ermöglicht wie und wo
knappe Ressourcen Personal wie das
knappe die Klappe Ressourcen Personal
eingesetzt werden kann eine sprechender
Initiativantrag unserer Fraktion hierzu
liegt vor die Pandemie der
Personalmangel die Energiekrise sowie
die Inflation setzen unser Kliniken
massiv unter Druck die wirtschaftliche
Prognose für 2022 ist alarmierend knapp
70 Prozent der Krankenhäuser machen
Verluste in den nächsten fünf Jahren
wird sich die wirtschaftliche Lage der
Krankenhäuser weiter verschlechtern
Insolvenzen drohen in nicht gekannter
Größenordnung aber vielleicht meine
Damen und Herren hält es diese
Bundesregierung mit der
insolvenzdoptrien von Herrn Habig
Menschen werden dann ganz einfach nicht
versorgt und mit den dann ganz einfach
nicht zu verhindernden Konsequenzen
meine Damen und Herren das ist
insbesondere für Menschen im ländlichen
Raum einen gravierendes Problem die
medizinische Versorgung im ländlichen
Raum droht ganz oder in großen Teilen
wegzubrechen diese Situation wird durch
den Fachkräftemangel weiter
verschlechtert ungeklärt um diesem
Gesetz nicht geregelt sind die Fragen
des Ausbaus der Telemedizin und
Telematik die hier zu einer Verbesserung
führen können das gilt auch für eine
weitere ambulantisierung wie auch die
angekündigte krankenhausstrukturreform
wollen Sie Herr Bundesminister dass
dieser Ausnahmezustand unserer
Krankenhäuser dauerhaft bleibt dass die
Krankenhäuser sich bei Notfällen
dauerhaft abmelden dieses Gesetz muss
dringend nachgebessert werden wir
stimmen dem Gesetz nicht zu herzlichen
Dank
Dietrich monstadt war das für die
Unionsfraktion er sitzt im
Gesundheitsausschuss noch ist allerdings
auch Zeit für die Beratung denn das ist
ja heute die erste Lesung dieses
Gesetzentwurfes des parlamentarischen
Verfahrens startet ja erst Cordula
Schulz Asche jetzt für die Bündnis
Grünen Damen und Herren Herr Kollege
monstadt ich
respektiere sie ja seit langem auch für
ihre Arbeit hier im Parlament aber ihre
Rede hier gerade hat mich doch sehr
erstaunt nicht nur dass sie hier
Vorwürfe erhoben haben nach einem Jahr
dieser Regierung wo zwei
Legislaturperioden acht Jahre lang
Gesundheitsminister der CDU hier regiert
haben und von daher wäre etwas
Selbstkritik angemessen gewesen und es
wäre sicher auch angemessen gewesen wenn
Sie zu dem Thema krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz und nicht über Hintern
Kunst geredet hätten danke schön die
professionell Pflegenden in diesem Land
warten seit Jahren auf spürbare
politische Entscheidungen die ihren
Alltag erleichtern die corona-pandemie
war eigentlich nur das Brennglas das auf
ein völlig ausgedörrtes
Gesundheitssystem entzündet hat und wir
können uns nicht länger damit begnügen
einzelne Feuer zu löschen sondern wir
brauchen endlich eine nachhaltige
Strategie für die Zukunft unseres
Gesundheitswesens
der demografische Wandel und die
demografische Wandel mit Alterung und
Fachkräftemangel ist eine der größten
Herausforderungen unseres Jahrhunderts
und trotz einiger Verbesserung auch
durch die Vorgängerregierung blieben
spürbare Reformen in der
krankenhauspflege aus und die
ampelregierung wird jetzt diese Reform
in Angriff nehmen die Arbeitsbedingungen
müssen besser werden damit Bürgerinnen
und Bürger die jetzt und in Zukunft in
ein Krankenhaus kommen noch gute Pflege
erwarten können dazu brauchen wir mehr
Pflegekräfte wir brauchen mehr
Pflegekräfte auch gerade bei den
Patienten und Patienten und das wollen
wir mit einer detaillierten
wissenschaftlichen
Personalbemessung erreichen diese ist
jetzt zu entwickeln für eine gute
Übergangslösung haben drei wesentliche
Akteure des deutschen Gesundheitswesens
nämlich der deutsche pflegerrat die
Deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft und
ver.di gemeinsam die
pflegepersonalregelung ppr2.0
arbeitet und dieser Vorschlag wird jetzt
endlich auf dem Weg gebracht den
professionelle Pflege braucht jetzt
deutliche Zeichen für schnelle
Verbesserung und dazu gehört auch eine
verbindliche Zusage der entsprechenden
Finanzierung das sage ich ausdrücklich
dies und andere Unklarheiten im
Gesetzentwurf werden wir in den nächsten
Tagen ausräumen wenn wir in unserem Land
steigende Nachfrage nach
Gesundheitsleistungen bei gleichzeitigem
Fachkräftemangel in Einklang bringen
wollen brauchen wir auch eine
Strukturreform des Gesundheitswesens
dazu gehört die Zusammenarbeit der
Krankenhäuser mit dem ambulanten Sektor
wir brauchen Zusammenarbeit der
Gesundheitsberufe und insbesondere
brauchen wir eine Aufwertung der
Fachpflege dazu gehören
personalbemessungsinstrumente mehr
berufliche Perspektiven erweiterte
Tätigkeitsprofile und wer
Selbstbestimmung der Pflegefachpersonen
und in diesem Sinne werden wir Pflege
Stärken nachhaltig aufwerten und zwar
konsequent in allen gesellschaftlichen
Bereichen nicht danke Ihnen
dr Christina Baum spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
um es gleich vorwegzunehmen mit diesem
Gesetz wird es keine einzige Pflegekraft
mehr im Gesundheitswesen geben denn die
Festlegung einer Personalbesetzung
ergibt überhaupt nur dann Sinn wenn
genügend Personal vorhanden steht ist
anscheinend hat Ihnen Herr Lauterbach
noch niemand gesagt dass es genau daran
mangelt und dies schon seit vielen
Jahren auch dass die geburtenstarken
Jahrgänge nun in Rente gehen und dann
über kurz und und über kurz oder lang
zumindest teilweise auch auf Pflege
angewiesen sein werden dazu braucht es
keine Weissagung diese demokratischen
Zahlen liegen allen seit langem vor
warum fragen sie nicht die direkt
Betroffenen nämlich die Pfleger selbst
welche Voraussetzungen erforderlich sind
um wieder einen personellen Zuwachs zu
generieren ich habe das getan dazu
gehört primär die Anerkennung und
Wertschätzung ihrer Arbeit ordentliche
Arbeitsbedingungen mit mehr Zeit für die
Patienten vernünftige Bezahlung und
weniger sinnlose Bürokratie im
Mittelpunkt der Pflege muss immer das
Patienten wohlstehen die liebevolle
Umsorgung der Kranken die wesentlich zur
Gesundung beiträgt
was sie persönlich Herr lautebach unter
Wertschätzung verstehen hat die ganze
Republik erfahren als sie den
ungeimpften Pflegekräften nach zwei
Jahren Einsatz zurufen ihre Arbeit hat
keinen Beitrag geleistet und damit einen
Spaltkeil in die Pflege getrieben haben
denn es sind auch die ungeimpften die
aktuell viele Orts den Betrieb am Laufen
halten und dies aufgrund der klugen
Entscheidungen der meisten
Gesundheitsämter die sie bis heute
weiterarbeiten ließen diese Mitarbeiter
haben damit mehr Realitätssinn und
Verantwortungsbewusstsein bewiesen als
unser krankheitsminister was geschieht
eigentlich mit den Krankenhäusern die
die vorgegebene Personalbesetzung nicht
einhalten können weil einfach keine
Leute zur Verfügung stehen die werden
dann obendrein zu ihren
Personalproblemen auch noch dafür
bestraft dass sich durch politische
Fehlentscheidungen die Rahmenbedingungen
in den letzten Jahren so dramatisch
verschlechtert haben dass niemand mehr
in diesem Beruf überhaupt arbeiten
möchte oder sie müssen ganze Abteilungen
schließen oder werden gezwungen Betten
abzubauen um eine Strafzahlung zu
entgehen das kann jeden einzelnen von
ihnen auch treffen dass sie vor einem
verschlossenen Krankenhaus stehen
es muss deshalb für viele Mitarbeiter
wie ein hohen klingen dass sie diesen
Entwurf krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz nennen auch die
jahrelange Praxis gut ausgebildetes
Personal aus ärmeren Ländern abzuziehen
war moralisch immer fragwürdig und von
vornherein zum Scheitern verurteilt weil
es keine dauerhafte Lösung sein kann
wir brauchen wieder ein System das auf
dem alten Grundverständnis basiert das
Gesundheitsversorgung da seins Fürsorge
ist das nicht Wirtschaftlichkeit oder
gar Profit eines Krankenhauses sondern
das Wohl der Patienten im Vordergrund
steht lassen Sie die Pfleger wieder in
Ruhe und ohne Bevormundung ihre Arbeit
machen von der sie ohnehin nichts
verstehen
streichen sie endlich das Gesetz zur
einrichtungsbezogenen Impfpflicht dann
werden viele in ihren Beruf zurückkehren
und neue hinzukommen der pflegemangel
ist kein Mangel an personalgrenzen er
ist und bleibt ein Mangel an politischer
Kompetenz dankeschön
[Applaus]
Nicole Westig ist die nächste Rednerin
für die FDP-Fraktion
sie ist für die Liberalen
pflegepolitische Sprecherin
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen endlich liegt er vor uns der
Gesetzentwurf zur pflegepersonalregelung
2.0 in unseren Kliniken damit werden wir
die Arbeitsbedingungen in der Pflege
verbessern
Pflegerat Krankenhausgesellschaft und
Verdi haben die PPR 2.0 in der letzten
Wahlperiode gemeinsam erarbeitet aber
lange schlummerte das Konzept in einer
Schublade des BMG jetzt setzt die
fortschrittskoalition dieses Vorhaben um
dabei müssen wir ehrlich sein
die PPR 2.0 löst nicht mit einem
Federstrich die Personalprobleme in
unseren Kliniken doch als lernendes
System liefert sie uns den
entscheidenden Schlüssel dazu als
Bundesregierung senden wir das Signal an
die Pflegenden wir sind bereit
Transparenz zu schaffen und lassen zu
das Lücken sichtbar werden denn aufgrund
ihrer übermäßigen Belastung können
pflegende nicht vernünftig ihre Arbeit
nachgehen und weder den Patienten noch
ihren eigenen Ansprüchen gerecht werden
das schafft großen Frust und führt im
schlimmsten Fall zum flexit und das
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dürfen
wir nicht länger zulassen
die PPR 2.0 weist uns auch den Weg raus
aus den pflegepersonaluntergrenzen denn
diese haben ihren Zweck nicht erfüllt
sie stellen einen reinen rechenwerkwert
dar und sagen nichts über die
Pflegequalität aus wir brauchen aber
eine Personalausstattung die sich am
tatsächlichen patientenbedarf orientiert
der Gesetzentwurf schafft dafür eine
Grundlage wir müssen allerdings noch
einige Verbesserungen vornehmen so
gehört gerade die Personalbemessung in
der Intensivpflege dazu und muss konkret
benannt werden als FDP möchten wir die
Pflege Wissenschaft und das
Pflegemanagement aktiv in den Prozess
einbinden denn sie liefern uns Antworten
auf die entscheidende Frage nach dem
qualifikationsmix und der besten
Aufgabenteilung im Team
das Gesetz ist ein erster Schritt zur
Verbesserung der Arbeitsbedingungen in
der Pflege damit dies gelingt müssen
weitere Vorhaben wie Zahnräder
ineinander greifen zum Beispiel der
Ministerrats angesprochen die
krankenhausstrukturreform denn mit ihr
können wir das Personal das uns zur
Verfügung steht auch zielgenau einsetzen
gemeinsam mit den Ländern müssen wir die
Pflegeausbildung stärken mit
einheitlichen Qualitätsstandards für die
Pflegeassistenz und dem Ausbau
akademisierter Pflege besonders der
Pflegepädagogik ebenso gilt es die
Anerkennung von Fachkräften aus dem
Ausland jetzt dringend zu beschleunigen
Frau Kollegin möchten Sie eine
Zwischenfrage zulassen aus wenn jetzt
fast am Ende
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen alles das
wird diese Koalition beherzt angehen ich
freue mich auf die weiteren Beratung ja
nicole wessig hat sich allerdings auch
für Verbesserung noch
wir hoffen hier und da an diesem
Gesetzentwurf auch der
Bundesgesundheitsminister selbst hat ja
schon gesagt der Gesetzentwurf möchte ja
Nachschärfen an der ein oder anderen
Stelle die Kliniken sollen offenbar
künftig keine Möglichkeit mehr haben mit
eigenen Tarifverträgen die
personalvorgaben zu umsehen zu umgehen
und die Kliniken die sollen
mittelfristig wenn Sie die
personalvorgaben nicht einhalten auch
sanktioniert werden
wirklich eine Frechheit eine Frechheit
gegenüber denjenigen die das ganze
erarbeitet haben eine Frechheit vor
allem gegenüber in Pflegekräften hier im
Land und dem gesamten medizinischen
Personal weil die mit der Vorlage nun
wirklich niemals entlastet werden aber
um es beispielhaft es ist beispielhaft
für das Ministerium und ein Lauterbach
und zwei in drei Punkten erstens
Lauterbach und sein Ministerium scheint
überhaupt nicht den Anspruch auf eine
Richtlinienkompetenz für den
Gesundheitsbereich zum sitzen oder zu
verlangen das hat man bei der
pandemiepolitik vermehrt feststellen
dürfen und nun steht im vorliegenden
Gesetz das Bundesfinanzministerium sogar
mit Vetorecht und da ja die Frage im
Raum steht woher das Geld in der
jetzigen angespannten Situation für die
Einstellung notwendiger Pflegekräfte
kommen soll ist der Entwurf mit dem
Vetorechten und wirklich ein schlechter
Witz und wir sorgen wir beschweren uns
immer wieder mal gemeinsam mit der CDU
dass der Gesundheitsminister so sehr
selten unseren ausschussbesuch Ausschuss
und ich will einfach vorschlagen wir
könnten uns mal ehrlich machen laden wir
den Finanzminister ein der taugt mir
politisch zwar noch weniger aber er
scheint irgendwie Entscheidungskompetenz
in dieser Regierung zu besitzen zweitens
der Koalitionsvertrag ist für
Lauterbacher Lauterbach obsolet und das
ist nun wirklich bemerkenswert von der
SPD nun nicht nur von der SPD aber es
Meister gewohnt dass vor der Wahl Sachen
versprochen werden danach aber nicht
umgesetzt werden bei Herrn Lauterbach
sind selbst nach der Wahl
unterschriebene Koalitionsverträge
Makulatur das Versprechen in
Koalitionsvertrag war wir setzen
kurzfristig PPR 2.0 um nun schreiben die
Erfinderinnen und Erfinder der
pflegepersonalregelung 2.0 da steht gar
nicht drin der Pflegerat DKG Deutsche
Krankenhausgesellschaft und ver.di haben
das Konzept erarbeitet sie schreiben ich
zitiere dem jetzt vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwurf fehlt der eindeutige
Bezug zur pflegepersonalregelung 2.0 und
weiter der Entwurf birgt die Gefahr dass
das gesamte personalbemessungssystem
verpufft die Umsetzung des PPR 2.0
bleibt offen
drittens und das verdient nun wirklich
irgendwie Respekt der
ankündigungsminister Lauterbach der ein
Jahr lang von Ankündigungen allein lebt
der seit einem Jahr bis auf einen
winzigen Pflege Bonus kein
koalitionsversprechen umsetzte schafft
es nun selbst ein Gesetz zu schaffen das
nahezu ausschließlich ankündigt prüft in
Aussicht stellt aber keine Regelung
umsetzt sondern das eigentlich
entscheidende in Verordnungen regeln
will das ist nun wirklich richtig
spannender Lauterbach wir werden im
Ausschuss einiges zu tun haben um das
alles noch irgendwie zu retten denn ich
fasse zusammen das ist das Gesetz eines
Ministers der von Ankündigungen lebt
Versprechen nicht einhält und die
rechtskompetenz dann sogar noch einen
anderen Minister abschiebt es könnte
witzig sein in der Pandemie ist es eine
Frechheit eine Frechheit für die
Pflegekräfte und das gesamte
medizinische Personal das seit Jahren
für ein Licht am Ende des Tunnels kämpft
dass den Laden am Laufen hält und nun
einen nicht regelnde Ankündigung erhält
die vom Finanzminister abhängig ist im
wahrsten Sinne also danke für nichts
Herr lauterbach danke für nichts
ja für Stirnrunzeln nicht nur bei der
Linken sondern auch bei Krankenkassen
ruft tatsächlich ist verantwortlich ein
Passes im Gesetzentwurf der nachträglich
noch eingearbeitet wurde da heißt es
Einzelheiten der Personalbemessung
würden durch
Rechtsverordnung im Einvernehmen mit dem
Bundesministerium der Finanzen
festgelegt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin ein
seltenes Bild mal die CDU und die Linke
in Eintracht zu sehen hier im Plenum
also
kommen wir zur Sachebene seit dem
Frühjahr 2020 hat die corona-pandemie
den Alltag im ganzen Land auf den Kopf
gestellt die Krise hat wie ein brendlers
bereits vorher bestehende Probleme oft
offengelegt und verstärkt
krankheitsbedingte Personalausfälle in
Krankenhäusern sind Mittel haben
mittlerweile flächendeckend zugenommen
und 90 Prozent davon in den Patienten an
Bereichen und am stärksten betroffen von
krankheitsbedingten Ausfällen sind die
Pflegekräfte viele Ausfälle also wegen
Corona die Personaldecke bei
Pflegekräften die ist dadurch noch
stärker ausgedünnt worden als sie es
jetzt schon ist und dementsprechend ist
der Fachkräftemangel offenkundig der
Mangel also an helfenden Händen und er
wurde spätestens mit der corona-pandemie
quasi demaskiert und verstärkt aber
Corona ist dabei leider nicht das
einzige Problem Pflegekräfte scheiden im
zunehmende Maße aus Gesundheitlichen
ohne vorzeitig aus ihrem Beruf aus sie
benennen dabei Belastungsfaktoren
Zeitdruck hoher Verwaltungsaufwand
organisatorische Mängel körperliche
Belastung und der demografische Faktor
verwandelt spielt ebenfalls eine Rolle
in den nächsten 10 bis 12 Jahren gehen
ca 500.000 Pflegefachkräfte in Rente der
Mangel wird sich also verstärken bei
steigendem Bedarf um den Bedarf abdecken
zu wollen braucht es mehr helfende Hände
dafür müssen wir neue Kräfte sicherlich
rekrutieren und alte zurückholen die
Studie der Hans-Böckler-Stiftung ich
fliege wieder wenn zu Berufsrückkehr und
Arbeitszeit Aufstockung von
Pflegekräften zeigt auf Fliege
Pflegefachkräfte während bereit in ihrem
Beruf zurückzukehren eure ihre Stunden
zu erhöhen wenn Sie dort eine deutliche
Verbesserung der Arbeitsbedingungen
vorfinden würden es gibt nicht dass eine
Patentrezept das ist uns allen klar den
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen erfordern
mehr Pflegepersonal und andersherum um
mehr Pflegepersonal gewinnen zu können
braucht es eine deutliche Verbesserung
der Arbeitsbedingungen
wir als Politik müssen dementsprechend
die Negativspirale aufbrechen denn bei
sehr vorsichtiger Kalkulation beläuft es
sich jetzt schon dass ca 300.000
Pflegekräfte in Vollzeit und in einem
optimistischen Szenario sogar auf
660.000 Vollzeitkräfte die zurückgeholt
werden könnten das heißt also wir
brauchen eine angemessene Bezahlung
durch weitere Aufwertung der
Tarifbindung aber Geld ist nicht alles
wir brauchen ein vereinfachte
Dokumentation Bürokratieabbau
Digitalisierung und essentiell dabei
ausreichende Zeit für eine gute Pflege
durch bedarfsgerechte Personalbemessung
verlässliche Arbeitszeiten durch
teambasierte Dienstplangestaltung sowie
ausfallmanagement im Koalitionsvertrag
meine Kollegin hat vorhin auch gesagt
haben sich die forschungskoalition dazu
darauf verständigt sie möchte
entsprechend mit dem hier vorliegenden
Entwurf zum krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz den nächsten Schritt
gehen für das ich Ihnen Herr Minister
und ihrem Haus ausdrücklich danke denn
wir gehen jetzt einen Schritt weiter wir
wollen eine angemessene
personalerstattung in der Pflege
Krankenhaus und essentiell um
Arbeitssituation der Pflegekräfte als
auch die Qualität der
Patientenversorgung spürbar zu
verbessern ziel ist es dabei mit dem
hier vorliegenden Gesetz Transparenz
über die personaldefizite herzustellen
und darüber hinaus Krankenhäuser zu
verpflichten die Defizite mittel bis
langfristig auszugleichen die Maßnahme
um die personalstation in der Pflege im
Krankenhäusern zu verbessern führen wir
entsprechend die pflegepersonalregelung
2.0 PPR 2.1 in zwei in drei Phasen einer
probungsphase ab Anfang 2023 eine
Einführungsphase ab Januar 24 und dann
einer dritten Phase der Konvergenzphase
die Einführung wird mit Augenmaß
Erfolgen der Wunsch wird nicht sofort
Wirklichkeit werden das muss uns klar
sein aber wir schaffen die
Rahmenbedingungen um den Bedarf der
Pflege so attraktiv wie nur möglich zu
machen
die fortschrittskoalition löst mit der
Einführung einer solchen verbindlichen
Personalbemessung im Krankenhaus ihr
Versprechen ein sich mittels
struktureller Veränderungen für gute
Arbeit in der Pflege einzusetzen gute
Arbeit
gute Arbeit in der Pflege hat nicht nur
mit Respekt und Anerkennung für
Beschäftigte zu tun ja auch das aber
insbesondere auch mit menschlicher Würde
von Patientinnen und Patienten die auf
eine qualitativ hochwertige Pflege
angewiesen sind in diesem Sinne freue
ich mich auf die ausschussberatung und
danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Simone Borchert hat jetzt das Wort für
die CDU CSU-Fraktion
Gesundheitsausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
als Folge der Pandemie herrscht nicht
nur in der klinischen Pflege ein
Ausnahmezustand
Arbeitsbelastungen
krankenheitsausfälle sind auf dem
Höchststand viele Beschäftigten halten
diese extreme Mehrfachbelastung nicht
mehr aus und wollen aus diesem Beruf
heraus
verstärkend kommt noch die Idee von
unserem Gesundheitsminister hinzu dass
jetzt die Nachtdienste wegfallen sollen
das sage ich das kann doch nicht
wirklich ihr Ernst sein damit gefährden
wir die Versorgung der Patientinnen und
Patienten und vor allem die Qualität der
Versorgung sie machen hier den ganzen
Zinnober angeblich um die Qualität zu
verbessern und dann kommen sie mit so
einer Idee um die Ecke das kann nicht
wirkliche Ernst sein
sie kochen auf die Einhaltung starre
Quoten und Schlüssel und damit
verschärfen sie die ganze Situation noch
legen Sie doch einfach mal die
Verantwortung in die Hände derjenigen
die die meiste Fachkompetenz haben und
setzen sie sich mal mit Kliniken und
Krankenhäusern an eigenen Tisch sie
versuchen nämlich gerade als Politik die
besseren Manager zu sein das
funktioniert so nicht
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
wegen der schlechten Bezahlung gehen die
Beschäftigten aber schon lange nicht
mehr auf die Straße die Vergütung für
die Pflegenden hat sich in den letzten
Jahren massiv verbessert was jetzt
fortgeführt werden muss ist die
Verbesserung der Arbeitsbedingungen mit
ihrem Vorschlag machen sie aber genau
das Gegenteil mit ihrem Gesetzesentwurf
verfehlen sie das Ziel vehement und das
mit ganz klarer Ansage ich mache Ihnen
das gerne auch an einem Beispiel sehr
deutlich sie wollen mit der PPR 20 ein
Neues
personalbemessungsinstrument einführen
ab dem Jahr 2025 veranschlagen sie 5000
zusätzliche Pflegekräfte im
Klinikbereich die Bundesregierung selbst
geht von einem zusätzlichen Bedarf von
63.000 vollzeitpflegekräften allein in
Krankenhäusern bis zum Jahr 2030 aus
diese Info haben wir aus einer kleinen
Anfrage das ist unterm Strich eine
Mogelpackung aller erster Güte das wird
Situation in der Pflege nicht gerecht
und meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
momentan ist es auch so dass es für
jeden Pflegenden ein Bett eine
vollständige Refinanzierung gibt durch
die Krankenkassen ob der Bedarf
vorhanden ist oder nicht das verschärft
das Problem der abwehrung es wird aber
keine einzige Pflegekraft zusätzlich
dadurch geben am Markt und deswegen
meine Damen und Herren überdenken Sie
diese starren Quotenregelung lassen sie
mehr Dynamik und Eigenverantwortung zu
schaffen sie endlich Anreize für ein
effizienten Einsatz von Beschäftigten
und finanziellen Ressourcen damit sorgen
sie dann nicht nur für bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen sondern sie entlasten
auch die Beitragszahler vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Simone Borchert von der cdu/csu-fraktion
ja bezweifelt das mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf bessere Arbeitsbedingungen
für Pflegekräfte zu erreichen sein und
sie hat auch noch mal die PPA 2.0
angesprochen nur noch einmal erklärt die
pflegepersonalregelung 2.0 ist
Instrument zur pflegepersonalbemessung
und heute in der ersten Lesung zu einem
sehr wichtigen Gesetz wie der
Bundesgesundheitsminister ist am Anfang
bereits eingeführt hat wir treten ein in
eine wichtige Phase
überfälliger Reformen im Bereich der
Pflege die seit vielen Jahren hätten auf
den Weg gebracht werden sollen wir haben
im Koalitionsvertrag eine Forderung von
Gewerkschaften von der Pflege selbst von
Fachgesellschaften von der Deutschen
Krankenhausgesellschaft aufgegriffen
endlich eine Personalbemessung im
Bereich der Pflege einzuführen die Licht
ins Dunkel von Defiziten im Bereich der
Krankenhaus der Krankenpflege bringt die
seit Jahren bekannt aber nicht
quantifizierbar ist die Koalition hält
Wort setzt um was die Forderung aus der
Gesellschaft ist und das ist Gegenstand
des Gesetzes
wenn wir uns nun mit dem vorliegenden
Gesetzesvorschlag auseinandersetzen ist
aus dem Kreis der Union zu hören gewesen
dass wir eine Situation haben wo den
Kliniken wo den Menschen im
Gesundheitswesen das Wasser bis zum Hals
steht ja das ist richtig wir erleben
gerade eine neue Herbst winterwelle die
in erhebliche Maße die Menschen in den
Krankenhäusern belastet die durch
Krankheitsausfälle dazu führt dass die
Versorgung an verschiedenen Stellen wie
es Herr Mund statt richtig vorgetragen
hat wirklich ernst zu nehmen gefährdet
ist das heißt das allererstes was wir
tun müssen die infektionsdynamik
kurzfristig zu bekämpfen die Länder sind
aufgefordert den Handlungsrahmen den der
Bund ihnen gegeben hat mit den
Infektionsschutzgesetz durch
maskenregeln im Innenraum umzusetzen um
hier kurzfristig Druck rauszunehmen und
gleichzeitig
gleichzeitig ist es wichtig dass wir die
langfristigen Reform auf den Weg bringen
indem wir durch eine personalabemessung
einerseits feststellen wo welcher Bedarf
konkret vorliegt ein Vorschlag der nicht
nur aus dem Kreis der aktuellen
Koalition kommt sondern der im übrigen
von ihnen aus der Union mit entwickelt
wurde sie aber nie den Mut hatten in den
acht Jahren wo sie das
Gesundheitsministerium verantwortet
haben Klarheit über das Defizit zu
schaffen was de facto in unserem
Gesundheitswesen besteht diese ehrlich
richtig hier ehrlich zu machen bedeutet
auch dass wir sehen wie sich über Jahre
eine Welle der Demografie auf unser
Gesundheitswesen aufgebaut hat die uns
jetzt gravierend bedroht in zwar in
doppelten Sinne einerseits durch
Pflegepersonal durch
gesundheitsfachkräfte die Ausscheiden
aufgrund von ihrem Alter andererseits
weil der Anzahl pflegebedürftiger
Menschen jetzt noch mal rapide zunimmt
und uns alle hier in diesem Haus in den
nächsten Jahren noch vielfach
beschäftigen wird insofern ist es
richtig an dieser Stelle nun
einzuschreiten mit Maßnahmen und hier
möchte ich noch ein Missverständnis
aufräumen was gerade vorgetragen wurde
nicht indem man einfach sagt nachts
kommt keiner zur Arbeit sondern indem
wir uns in Zeiten knapper Ressourcen
fragen welche Fälle müssen denn wirklich
im Krankenhaus behandelt werden oder
welche können sinnvollerweise aus
medizinischen Gründen ambulant viel
besser versorgt werden und Maßnahmen in
diesem Sinne zum Gegenstand dieses
Gesetzes zu machen hier Behandlung in
den armbolanden Bereich zu verlagern das
werden wir im Rahmen des
parlamentarischen Verfahren intensiven
gemeinsam miteinander beraten
gegebenenfalls ergänzen ich lade also
die
Oppositionsfraktion ein hier in ein
konstruktiven Dialog einzutreten nicht
über das Gesetz zu schimpfen sondern
echte Probleme zu lösen vielen Dank
sagt Janosch Damen der
gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen so jetzt
hören wir hier am Rednerpult Maximilian
Funke Kaiser für die FDP
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen damit das nicht
zu kurz kommt dieser Gesetzesentwurf der
ist auch ein notwendiger Aufschlag in
Richtung Verbesserung Entlastung und
Fortschritt des Gesundheitswesens durch
Digitalisierung und Technik liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das Ziel das
muss sein die Verbesserung der Pflege
der Vorsorge und der Versorgung der
Patientinnen und Patienten und
gleichzeitig eine Entlastung der
pflegenden und Fortschritt ist da das
Stichwort wenn wir über digital Herz
sprechen
die Möglichkeiten der Digitalisierung im
Gesundheitswesen die werden nun in einem
ersten Schritt endlich in die Tat
umgesetzt und ich möchte betonen es ist
ein erster Schritt und es werden auch
weitere Schritte durch die
Digitalisierungsstrategie die gerade von
ihnen angestoßen worden sind Herr
Lauterbach im BMG folgen wir machen das
nicht der digitalisierungswert sondern
wir machen das zum Wohle der
Patientinnen und Patienten durch beste
medizinische Versorgung und Vorsorge
machen das zum wurde der Pflegekräfte
durch einen erheblichen Abbau der
dokumentationsaufwendungen und zum Wohle
der Leistungserbringer durch einen
lückenlosen Informationsaustausch liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und genau dafür enthält dieses Gesetz
einige Stellschrauben zum ersten gehen
wir zum ersten Mal einen Schritt der
verpflichtenden Interoperabilität ganz
im Sinne der digitalstrategie der
Bundesregierung das ist auch ein
Paradigmenwechsel der digitalpolitik
hier in Deutschland dadurch beflügeln
wir die Verbreitung von zentralen
Anwendungen der
telematik-infrastrukturen Stärken auch
die Rechte der Leistungserbringer
zweitens stärken wir die
Nutzerfreundlichkeit digitaler
Anwendungen und drittens verbessern wir
die Verfügbarkeit und Nutzbarkeit von
Daten ja liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Telematik Infrastruktur die es mit
ihren zahlreichen Anwendungen wieder
elektronischen Patientenakte des
erezeptes und dem digitalen
medikationsplans eine Papier
verschlingende Raupe Nimmersatt sein
aktuell aber das hat nach dieser
Legislaturperiode ein Ende und dieses
krankenhauspflege entlassungsgesetz das
ist ein erster wichtiger Schritt in
dieser Evolution es ist quasi der Kokon
ein wichtiges Stadium der Reife und
bekanntlich gefolgt das schöne darauf
folgend in diesem Sinne herzlichen Dank
Maximilian Funke Kaiser hat hier für die
FDP als deren digitalpolitischer
Sprecher gesprochen und sie haben gehört
warum nämlich weitere Regelungen dieses
hier vorgelesen vorgelegten Gesetzes
betreffen eben die Weiterentwicklung der
Digitalisierung beispielsweise
Nutzerfreundlichkeit von digitalen
Anwendungen wie zum Beispiel die Nutzung
des elektronischen Rezeptes
nahmen die schnell und spürbar die
Arbeitsbedingungen verbessern
kurzfristig führen wir zu verbindlichen
Personalbemessung im Krankenhaus die
pflegepersonalregelung PPR 2.0 als
übergangsinstrument mit dem Ziel eines
bedarfsgerechten qualifikationsmixes ein
was ich hier zitiere er klatschen allein
reicht nicht das hat ihnen die Pflege
immer wieder gesagt was ich
was ich hier zitiere ist rund ein Jahr
alt und steht im Koalitionsvertrag der
aktuellen Regierung unter kurzfristig
verstehe ich dass etwas in den ersten
100 Tagen aktiv ins Parlament
eingebracht wird und unter verbindlich
verstehe ich eben gerade nicht dass man
ein erprobtes System noch mals in eine
Erprobungsphase schickt wie sie es tun
und die Entscheidungshoheit aus dem
Parlament über eine Verordnung in die
Hände des Ministeriums und des Ministers
legt
dass dann de facto ohne Beteiligung des
Parlaments in eine ganz andere Richtung
entwickelt werden kann und verbindlich
gegenüber der Pflege ist mit Sicherheit
nicht um das haben die Kollegen
angesprochen dass das Ganze
unterfinanzierungsvorbehalt also
praktisch in die Hände von Christian
Lindner gelegt wird deshalb fordere ich
Sie
auf die Dramatik die sich selbst im
Koalitionsvertrag beschrieben haben
ernstzunehmen und es nicht dem
Ministerium zu überlassen was mit der
Pflege passiert und ja es braucht eine
Revolution in der Pflege und wenn sie es
ernst meine mit dem Menschen in der
Pflege reichen wir Ihnen als
Oppositionsfraktion auch die Hand wir
stehen bereit für eine gemeinsame
konzertierte parlamentarische und das
ist der Unterschied parlamentarische
Aktion Pflege mit einem Bündel an
Maßnahmen den wir nicht einem
Fachausschuss der Arbeits- und
sozialministerkonferenz der Länder
überlassen können denn die sind im
Moment federführend in dem was
eigentlich getan werden müsste denn das
wird dem Anspruch eines nationalen
Parlaments bei weitem nicht gerecht und
dass sie fachlich dringend Hilfe nötig
und benötigen wurde vorhin auch schon
angesprochen das sieht man nämlich im
Gesetzentwurf sie veranschlagen mit der
neuen PPR 2.0 bis 2025 denn dann wird
erst das ganze Instrument scharf
geschalten 5000 zusätz eine Pflegekräfte
im Klinikbereich und gleichzeitig
beantwortet diese Bundesregierung auf
unsere Anfrage hin das bis zum Jahr 2030
zusätzlich 63.000 zusätzliche
Vollzeitkräfte im Klinikbereich
gebraucht werden das passt nicht
zusammen und dann frage ich mich ja was
denn jetzt deshalb lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam gerne in einer übergreifenden
parlamentarischen konzertierten Aktionen
Verbindlichkeit Schnelligkeit und
Wirksamkeit für die Pflege auf den Weg
bringen die Pflegekräfte in unserem Land
haben diese Unterstützung verdient
ja sagt Emmi Zollner hier für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion zum Abschluss dieses
Tagesordnungspunktes die Debatte hat
gezeigt dass doch hier noch einiges an
Bedarf besteht was man im
parlamentarischen Verfahren noch mal
besprechen könnte nicht nur von der
Opposition sondern auch aus den Reihen
der koalitionsfraktion hat man da doch
das ein oder andere gehört auch der
Bundesgesundheitsminister selbst hat ja
angekündigt den Gesetzentwurf doch an
der ein oder anderen Stelle noch mal
nach zu schärfen das ganze geht jetzt in
die Ausschüsse